there is a real danger of losing
our tenure on this planet all together
[Music]
we've got to care about this matter of
global warming because if we don't do
anything about it there won't be anybody
here
[Music]
during my lifetime
the big change that's happened to the
world has been the development of
machines and devices and inventions it's
about time we went back to taking an
interest in the environment
the earth has an impossible atmosphere
for it to have hand by accident the odds
against it run into
countless billions to one against
so something's going on
[Music]
i tend to think
of the earth
as alive in a sense
like an
animal or a plant or any other living
thing
gaia looks after us
what happens to the planet
when more carbon dioxide is put in the
air
the earth will get hotter
it will heat up to a point where no life
on it of our kind will be possible
take an interest in the natural world in
plants and animals and things that grow
naturally
not worry too much at all about
schooling there's three r's yes they're
very important but all the other stuff i
think
could be ditched in favor of a better
understanding of the world
there are answers of various kinds but i
think it it needs
the right sort of politics to change
people's thinking about these things and
i'd like to see these youngsters using
their energies and their talent in this
way rather than looking for some techie
answer because
i don't think the answer is going to be
come that way i think we have all the
things needed to stop global warming
we're just not using them thanks for
watching if you enjoyed that be sure to
check out these videos next and if you
haven't already hit the subscribe button
and click the bell to get a notification
each time we upload a new video